Current House, I should say,
Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy is warning
House Republicans get in line
and support his bid for speaker
or expect disaster watch
having the challenge on the floo
is never going to be positive.
And will you turn the floor over
The Democrats will do it.
This is very fragile
that we are the only stopgap
for this Biden administration.
And if we don't do this right,
the Democrats can take the major
If we play games on the floor,
the Democrats can end up picking
who the speaker is.
We need to do this
for the American people.
We either are successful togethe
or we will fail individually
and we will not be given the pos
or the opportunity
to be in the majority again.
So at least five House Republica
as of now they won't support
McCarthy's leadership bid. So no
What is next?
So joining us now,
CNN political analyst
Jonathan Martin, senior
political columnist at Politico.
Good morning.
So, John, it's good to see you i
So let's talk it's
but this is about raw numbers. O
So McCarthy,
these 218 votes,
if every other lawmaker
besides those five on
vote on party lines, he's
two votes short.
So is he really in danger here?
He's in real danger.
Now, the good news for McCarthy
that today is December 1st,
not January 1st.
So he's got a little bit of time
Those those numbers.
Look,
when you're the leader
of a party in Congress,
you have a lot of tools
at your disposal, right?
You can only call for carrots an
And for the next month, McCarthy
is going to be doing a lot of th
trying to reel in just enough pe
with sort of various carrots, ki
a couple sticks
to cook questions
that are kind of combined,
if not McCarthy, who?
And how is this different from P
Ryan in 2015?
Well, the obvious back of
what would be Steve Scalise
who's the number two from Louisi
Dodd's home state
who is somebody who's seen the s
you know
mainstream conservative
and isn't as despised
I guess by the far right
as McCarthy is in the House.
And in terms of the Ryan questio
This is part of the challenge
the House GOP has.
There is no sort of Paul Ryan
waiting in the wings here
who can step forward
and be
a sort of broadly popular
and sort of a super impressive p
Its no offense against Steve Sca
He's perfectly capable
but he just doesn't
have the sort of background
that Paul Ryan had.
Ryan had been on a national tick
in 2012 obviously before he beca
speaker of the House.
Well I've been struck by the Rep
who have come out
in support of Kevin McCarthy
at this very difficult time.
He is saying basically
if we don't stay united,
Democrats are going to end up pi
who's our House speaker
because the margin is so dang sl
Yeah, look,
this doesn't happen in Congress,
but it has happened
in states over the years
where you have a very tight legi
and there are
some kind of a bipartisan deal
to elect a compromise candidate.
I think in a very polarized Wash
that's still pretty darn unlikel
that you would see
that kind of
a pick emerge from the political
if you will.
I think it's more likely, Caitli
that we'll see Steve Scalise as
conservative backup plan
if McCarthy can't get there.
Can you talk about rail strike
and the president?
So Amtrak, Joe Wright and Union
and someone who voted in favor o
in a similar proposal in 92.
This is the president
Biden is now bucking the unions
and saying
it's just too economically devas
to let there be a strike.
What are we What is the big cont
Christmas and not wanting to be
criticized.
Yeah.
I mean look
I think the fact is is that Bide
fear of a rail strike
causing a massive economic disru
before the holidays
is the biggest driver in this.
And I think
he just wants to get a deal done
because he feels like the fallou
this could be devastating
if there is not an agreement.
The real peril here, he believes
he has more peril
if there is a strike
rather than if he upsets members
Yeah.
And what's striking about
this is
that labor has been somewhat
quiet about this.
They're not out there
sort of jamming Biden day in, da
So he's got some latitude on thi
But the House is passing this.
They've passed two separate prov
One is this agreement,
one that they had in September.
One is for the sick paid leave,
which is what has been really at
the center of this.
Is the Senate going to pass?
That seems less likely
because in the Senate,
you have to find ten folks in th
to vote for that sick leave prov
It doesn't seem like today
they're going to be able
to find those votes.
So can you talk to us about Gavi
I'd love to. Okay.
So you have reporting on this.
What is
what is he
he's he has said,
I'm not going to run in a run.
I spent election night in Sacram
with Governor Davis,
some kind of embedded with him
in the governor's mansion
watching the returns.
And it was fascinating
because here's somebody who's
very ambitious person,
even mayor of San Francisco
ten and governor now
governor, he's won three electio
in five years, guys.
Because he won the recall last y
And here he is
in the biggest state in America,
the fifth biggest economy in the
And he's got sort of nowhere to
because like a lot of Democrats
he's bumping
up against an incumbent presiden
who appears to be poised
to run for reelection.
So what Newsom told me
is, look, I'm
not going to challenge Biden,
but that
he has conveyed to the White Hou
very directly,
you know, use me
send me out there as a surrogate
Sort of a super surrogate to con
folks like Ron DeSantis
and Greg Abbott in Texas.
Deploy me out there.
I think what he's getting at
is that if Biden does run again
in 20, 24,
when he'll be almost 82 years ol
that's going to be
a Rose Garden campaign.
And Biden
is going to need people in the p
to go out there on the trail
who are doing that kind of work.
I think Newsom is basically sayi
sign me up for that.
That's interesting.
So he's basically
saying he doesn't expect Biden
to have this really aggressive c
that he'll be doing.
I think that's the unspoken.
But I happen to be there.
When Biden
called him on the phone that nig
and I heard Newsom
side of the conversation
total dumb luck, happenstance,
and he directly told Biden, he s
put me in, coach, I'm ready to g
Hey, there you go.
Timing good reporter, dumb luck.
Dumb luck lucky then. Good. Righ
Both end.
Thanks you all